le dakar ne fêtera donc pas son 30e
anniversaire le rallye était aujourd'hui
annuler les deux mille cinq cents
concurrents et accompagnateurs
s'apprêtait à prendre le départ à
lisbonne au portugal
mais les organisateurs ont choisi la
prudence depuis quelques jours le
ministre des affaires étrangères les
mettant en garde contre les risques
encourus lors des huit étapes prévues en
mauritanie un pays où quatre touristes
français ont été assassinés à la veille
de noël
retour sur cette journée et cette
décision qui est une première avec
julien benetteau 0 km au compteur les
rutilantes mécanique kit lisbonne ce
soir sans avoir goûté la moindre d'une
épilogue d'un jour maudit qui avait
commencé par l' attente fébrile de la
décision des organisateurs
le dakar 2008 ne partira pas bivouac en
état de choc
551 pilote privé de course pour la
première fois depuis sa création il ya
30 ans le dakar est annulé a appelé les
gens me couper la main monde de
l'annonce détiennent la vigne beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de déception parce que
c'est vrai que là car c'est une année de
préparation une année de
on pense qu'à ça anéanti le projet de
toute une vie certains pilotes amateurs
ont investi jusqu'à 70 mille euros dans
l' aventure le dakar annulé la faillite
guette les écuries semi professionnels
et ils ne pourront pas rembourser les
clients ni les sponsors parce que trois
3 mois de manoeuvres des pièces quand je
crois que c'est très compliqué ça avait
une très bonne ambiance
face à la menace terroriste les
dirigeants du rallye dit avoir obéi à la
raison d'état
d'après les services secrets français
des groupes de la mouvance al qaida
projette d'attaqué des français en
mauritanie des menaces qui font suite à
l'assassinât le 24 décembre dernier de
quatre touristes français dans le sud du
pays
depuis hier le quai d'orsay déconseille
fortement aux français de se rendre en
mauritanie
huit des quinze étapes du parcours étant
programmés dans ce pays
l'organisation du rallye devenait
impossible l'avenir de la course en
afrique est désormais en suspens pense
pas qu'un organisateur aujourd'hui quels
qu'ils soient prennent le risque de
retourner fériés des preuves sur ce
continent se cantonne continent là et ça
c'est dramatique ce soir le gouvernement
mauritanien critiquent la décision
française et on parle déjà d'une
possible délocalisation du rallye vers
le continent sud américain